[موسيقى]
انا اكاديبي
ماذا يمكن ان اعمل في مثل هذه الظروف قلت
لابد ان اراهن على ما اتقنه على ما احصنه
وسيرتي كلها اكاديميه فبالتالي هذا
الكرسي عانى وجه بعض الصعوبات لكن كنت
مدير عام لم يعني لم يكن يعترض فبالتالي
اعلنت عن الكرسي وبدات اضع له برامج محدده
انشطه ثقافيه من النوع
الجد والعالي مع كبار باحثين المفكرين من
داخل فرنسا ومن خارجها وبعد فتره استحدثنا
تكريم شخصيه من الوزن الثقيل من النجوم
وبداناها بواحد اظن اشهر اشهر فيلسوف في
فرنسا سنوي وترجمه بعض الكتب عن طريق
الثقافيه السعوديه ومعروف ادجار مورا ثم
العروي ثم هشام جعيط
ورشدي راشد واندري ميكيل وفلان يعني من
الاسماء الوازنه جدا
وايضا كان لدينا منذ البدايه
خطه لمشروع موازي وهو مئه كتاب الذي
تعاونا على انجازه بالشراكه مع جاسم
[موسيقى]
لكن اعتقد انه
لحسن الحظ والفضل شراكات
مثمره بناءه جاده مع جالس الملك فيصل في
الرياض مع محمد شحرور
اظنني استطعت ان
اقدم شيء نوعي للمعهد وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بجنوب المتوسط بالشركه العربي للامانه
ورجل سياسي من الطراز الاول لكن استاذ
جامعي ومثقف كبير وبالتالي ادرك ان ان
هناك شيء جديد
ربما يتطور وانا لو لو بقيت
وكان عندي دعم بالتاكيد سيحضر المعهد في
العالم العربي اكثر واكثر لكن انا وصلت
الى مرحله التشبع مالي من باريس وتشبع من
المعهد وفي لحظه من اللحظات انا اعتقد
الانسان الذي يتمتع بقدر من الحكمه انه
اذا لم يعد لديه اضافات نوعيه عليه ان
ينسحبه وهو في الذره والا والا يصبح مثل
زعماء العالم الثالث يظل الواحد الى ان
يخرب كل ما بناته والحياه
[موسيقى]